I hate plastic that's why we engulfed on
a 15 year mission to turn that into
something that we actually want we have
collected around 750 new materials
that's coming from our daily coast
consumer waste it can go into any
consumer product at lower cost higher
performance Chris oh let me show up a
hand who actually recycled something
today Wow okay
this is a wait we're audience but guess
what guess what there's actually in the
United States we have a lowest recycling
rate of all the developed nations as
plateauing at 34 percent recycling rate
you look at the waste here it has tires
a pair of waist on top of plastic bags
and PT bottles I think this is the one
of a big problem here no one actually
wants to be responsible for all that
ways that we're creating we are
responsible all of us here are
responsible for this mess our solutions
we have to make trash sexy and this is
what National Geographic is so good
about for us engineer that is
engineering porn okay so why is that
because this is the highest performance
animal in the ocean it's the fastest it
has the scale that's optimized for speed
and just a pure physical form is no
waste zero waste everything is
considered everything is designed but
this is what we get every grain of rice
every week every breath you eat has 20%
wastes fiber waste every PT bottle all
these are perfectly non-toxic material
that can constantly recycle reuse and
then we have a growing a ways electronic
ways huge amount of it has precious
metal and has a lot of toxic element
let me get nerdy a little bit here okay
why we are not turning that into product
today if you touch your clothes there's
no recycle content in it there's the CEO
sitting on the environment that we're in
has no recycle content in it this is a
problem why why not the reason is
because the polymer chain got broken in
a recycling process
then how do you make them strong again
if you're weak animal weak animal cannot
be sexy maybe they are but but you know
they're not very sexy so we we appeal we
are actually drawn to pretty things so
how do you make that sexy again we have
to use fiber to bridge in between and
this is a we go back to history the
Romans built cement aqueducts Chinese
built walls all with agricultural waste
grind it down into these powder form
they mix into the cement what it does is
it has silicon dioxide in it amorphous
silicon dioxide it's a natural glue it's
actually forming these broken polymer
chain if you mix into it actually stop
to come together conglomerates into much
much stronger materials the ancient does
it why aren't we doing that today so
that's one of a solution how we
reinforce material using organic waste
so why are we doing this toxicities this
is a piece of leather and that's a piece
of recycled PT fabric on the side just
look at how many steps that's required
to produce a process a piece of leather
fabric versus a piece of recycled PT
waste every step required carbon
footprint energy chemical on the recycle
PDS I only use water heat and knife to
cut the pieces down why aren't we doing
this more we invest seven new materials
a month we have collected around 750 new
materials that's coming from our daily
compost consumer waste but the problem
is no one wants to buy them okay so we
have the Pioneer making up new
applications so I'll show you very
quickly what we did this is what we call
molecular cooking molecular cooking are
all levels molecular gastronomy at the
marketing front new pioneering
engineering and designing and marketing
fronts it can go into any consumer
product at lower cost higher performance
we have built 40 storey tower with trash
campuses nice story tall Building Museum
we just finished a biggest eat waste
recycling plant that we turn the waste
of a waste into all the building
structure we have work on the food waste
recycling plant in Taiwan and we're also
doing a car waste recycling plant that's
finishing this year this looks like a
piece of marble it's not it's right here
it's a piece of recycled PT
non-woven no chemical added heat press
structural material and it's also a air
purifier okay
made from cigarette waste which is
cabaco which i smoked for many years
okay it can be formed shape into a lot
of different format we turn it into this
in Milan this year this is a pavilion
it's actually inspired by the natural
lung molecule and that's actually
capturing for Mada high in the air and
it's integrated with electronics it's
all interlock single material no glue
and I want you to focus on the waste of
the waste of that cigarette but
production process which are those
chairs we actually turn that into this
furniture product using the cigarette
butts so the project's call anything but
okay and this process allows other
designer goal will lead to do even more
different type of furniture products
please this has to look sexy to you now
because this is a leftover of a typical
German beer festival okay look at all
that material that's out there this is a
possibility here and we turn that all
that crap he waste food waste recycle
Nike shoes into recycled Nike store in
New York you can go see in Paris Lamar a
you can go see in Milan London you can
see all these stores that's made from a
pair of ways and a ways and any type of
ways we scale across 23 countries taking
portable manufacturing machineries into
developed world because we want to keep
the trash in the developed world not to
ship to India China Taiwan anywhere else
thank you this abilene means the garbage
people but the funny thing is is that
they don't believe there's such thing as
garbage they see value and things that
other people can't see the value
and they're very proud